this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer the United States
military has the strongest and most
diverse Navy in the world the US
military's fleet of aircraft carriers is
so large and makes the US Navy the
second largest Air Force in the world
second only to the actual US Air Force a
single Nimitz class aircraft carrier
like the USS Ronald Reagan a 6.2 billion
dollar nuclear-powered ship can carry
twice the aircraft as any other foreign
carrier which makes it even more
shocking that it was sunk by a single
diesel-powered swedish submarine during
war games in 2005 a single submarine
that cost the same as a single f-35 at a
hundred million dollars managed to sneak
by an entire carrier task force with
anti-submarine defences to enter the red
zone and score multiple torpedo hits on
the US Ronald Reagan sinking it
virtually before shrinking back into the
vast ocean undetected this was just one
of many exercises where the Swedish
Gatlin class submarine proved too
stealthy for the world's strongest Navy
the new submarine proved so threatening
that the US military leased the Swedish
sub for an additional year to develop
strategies to counter the silent threat
so what set the Gotland apart from other
subs the submarines primary instrument
to detect enemy subs is Soner sonar is
essentially a finely tuned ear that
works like a whales or dolphins
echolocation to create a 3d map of the
ocean around it there is active sonar
where the submarine will send out a
sound pulse called a ping and listen for
the reflections but in warfare this
isn't a sound strategy as the ping is
detected by enemies to give your exact
location so passive sonar is used where
no ping is emitted and instead you
simply listen these electronic ears are
so accurate that the nationality of
submarines can be determined based on
the operating frequency of the
alternating current used in its power
systems the 60 Hertz alternating current
of the u.s. sub could be differentiated
from the 50 Hertz of European subs if
the transformers and other electronics
were not adequately insulated from the
hole the Swedes managed to create a
submarine so silent that it was
practically undetectable by passive
sonar so how do they do this at such a
low cost the garland was the first
submarine in the world to use a Stirling
engine as its power generator Stirling
engines are not a new concept
the first being created and patented by
Robert Sterling in 1816 inspired by a
series of high-pressure steam boiler
explosions at the beginning of the
Industrial Revolution Stirling wanted to
create a safer engine that did not
require such high pressures I can't be
arsed tried to animate this old drawing
so let's go for something simpler he did
this by creating a closed cylinder
containing a fixed mass of gas
permanently sealed with him here one
side of the piston cylinder has a large
buffer space which allows for a
relatively constant pressure on this
side of the piston while the other side
fluctuates and pressure due to
alternating heating cycles when heat is
applied to the outside of the cylinder
the pressure increases causing the
piston to move until the pressure
equalizes now if we cool the outside of
the cylinder what a heat exchanger the
pressure will drop and once again the
piston will move this is our basic
pressure cycle to create a mechanical
work but this is an insanely inefficient
system as most of the energy we put into
the system as heat is lost during the
cooling cycle not to the gas but the
actual cylinder wall which provides no
mechanical work Robert Sterling solved
this by adding a displacer piston which
can drive the gas from one end of the
cylinder to the other allowing this end
to be permanently hot and the other to
be permanently cold so the cylinder wall
is no longer experiencing a temperature
cycle the pressure cycle here works
slightly differently first the air on
the hot end expands and causes the
displacer to move into contact with the
power piston displacing more air from
the cold end to be heated and expanded
allowing work to be done on the power
piston the air on the hot end now has
nowhere to go and so is driven to the
cold end where it is cooled and
contracts causing work to be done once
again on the power piston this is our
new pressure cycle the efficiency of
this system can be increased further by
placing what is essentially a heat
battery in the tubes between the hot and
cold cylinders this conserves a huge
amount of heat that would otherwise be
wasted during the cooling cycle and
gives the heat back to the air as it
travels back through Robert Stirling
dubbed this the regenerator now we have
the foundations of a useful engine by
incorporating a coolant system and a
heating chamber we create a larger
temperature differential to drive the
engine and the efficiency can be further
increased by increasing the number of
tubes connecting the hot and cold spaces
along with the number of regenerators
and adding fins to increase the surface
area of these tubes to allow for
transfer did I say simplified sorry I
meant easier to read
Stirling engines ultimately fell into
obscurity a stronger steel became
available to make steam engine boilers
safer but I've seen a resurgence in
recent decades with the Gotland being
the most famous implementation the
Gotland uses two stirling engines to use
diesel and liquid oxygen to provide heat
which in turn runs at 75 kilowatt
generators these generators can run an
electric motor directly or charge
batteries that can provide a huge boost
in speed when needed all the while the
exhaust is compressed and stored onboard
allowing the sub to stay submerged for
up to two weeks vastly longer than any
other diesel powered submarine so why is
it so silent compared to other
submarines it doesn't require much
explanation as to why an internal
combustion engine using tiny controlled
explosions for power tends to lead to
some noise while the multibillion-dollar
nuclear-powered submarines need to pump
huge volumes of coolant to their
reactors to prevent a meltdown causing
enough noise to be detectable by passive
sonar within a certain range on top of
this recently Declassified intelligence
suggests that Russian submarines are
using these instruments to detect the
faint trail of radiation left in the
wake of these nuclear-powered submarines
giving the swedish submarine another way
of avoiding detection this is a
fascinating application of the laws of
thermodynamics understanding and
applying the laws of science is the
closest to a real-life superpower in
this world so why not unlock your super
power of understanding the universe by
taking this course on astronomy on
brilliant this course will take you from
learning about the tools astrophysicists
used to observe the universe through to
the calculations that will allow you to
peer into the future of the universe
brilliant is a problem-solving website
that teaches you to think like an
engineer you can dive in and start
learning about a huge range of topics
starting from basic physics and working
your way up to more complicated topics
to support real engineering and learn
more about brilliant go to brilliant org
ford slash
real engineering and sign up for free
the first 73 people to sign up with this
link will get 20% off their annual
premium subscription I get to learn and
solve these kinds of problems for a
living and I love it it gives me that
warm glow a feeling inside when I
finally conquer a difficult problem
actively challenging your brain on a
daily basis and getting that endorphin
of a job well done is great for your
mental health brilliant even have an app
where you can challenge yourself on the
go as always thank you to my patrons and
thank you for watching if you'd like to
join the real engineering community I've
recently set up a subreddit where we
discuss everything engineering related
and more the link for that is in the
description